tiempo de hablar de economía las 24 y
saludamos entonces a nuestra periodista
daniel hablando en que nos va a contar
lo más importante de hoy daniela
bienvenida brasilia responde a eeuu
sobre las restricciones que le impuso al
acero de este país suramericano
hola liliana buenas noches pues mire
eeuu venía disfrutando de una exención
de aranceles sobre 750 millones de
litros de etanol que le exportaba a
brasil pero ese beneficio expiró el
pasado domingo y hasta el momento no se
ha renovado por parte del gobierno eso
quiere decir que eeuu tendrá una tarifa
plena del 20 por ciento en el país que
más etanol se compra en este momento
como en todo hay ganadores y perdedores
los productores de maíz habían
presionado para que no regresara a este
impuesto pero la industria de caña de
azúcar quería lo contrario el etanol es
una pieza comercial clave entre estos
dos países liviana pero también lo es el
acero al que eeuu acaba de imponerle
restricciones como usted lo dijo así que
esta respuesta del país suramericano
podría considerarse como una pequeña
fractura de una relación de por sí
bastante
entre los presidentes donald trump y
jair bolsonaro pues veremos qué pasa
daniela revivió la polémica justamente
entre eeuu por el millonario programa de
préstamos a las empresas y hace unas
semanas este programa de alivio de más
de medio billón de dólares estuvo bajo
la lupa porque los recursos que eran
para pequeñas y medianas compañías los
habían recibido millonarios empresarios
y esto este programa entregó al menos 52
millones de préstamos condonables sin
embargo hoy resucitó la polémica porque
la cámara de representantes dominada por
los demócratas lanzó un informe que dice
que los pequeños y medianos empresarios
están despilfarrando la plata o
cometiendo fraudes
el subcomité identificó más de 10.000
préstamos a empresas que recibieron
múltiples préstamos una violación a los
términos del programa
se otorgaron otros miles de préstamos a
empresas que no eran elegibles para el
programa o que tenían señales de alerta
que indicaban un posible fraude
daniela el congreso de chile aprobó la
extensión de la ley de protección al
empleo pues después de semanas enteras
de polémica este proyecto ahora pasa a
sanción presidencial y lo que hace es
flexibilizar la actual ley que permite
que las empresas suspendan los contratos
de sus trabajadores si se han visto
afectadas por la pandemia de el
coronavirus de esta manera los empleados
pueden acceder a un seguro que les
reconoció hasta el 70% de lo que venían
devengando y también extiende los giros
que ya no serán máximo de cinco sino
nueve si la pandemia se extiende en el
más pesimista de los casos también los
empleados pueden acordar con sus jefes
la reducción de jornada para no perder
el empleo
y es que chileno atraviesa por un buen
momento como muchos países su tasa de
desocupación está en un máximo histórico
del 13,1 por ciento y se estima que casi
dos millones de personas han perdido su
trabajo en estos últimos meses
danielle y la tasa de desempleo en la
unión europea aumentó levemente durante
el mes de julio si la oficina de
estadísticas de este bloque comunitario
explicó que en julio
había 15 a 2 millones de personas sin
empleo en los 27 países miembros
concretamente la tasa de desocupación se
ubicó en el 72 % en julio y dejó en un
mes a 336 mil personas más sin trabajo
si observamos la tendencia vemos que ha
venido subiendo lentamente desde febrero
cuando era del 65 por ciento debido a la
pandemia las proyecciones sobre
recuperación económica en europa son más
optimistas o pesimistas según el país
por ejemplo el gobierno de alemania
vaticinó hoy que a pesar de que seguirá
en recesión ésta será más suave de lo
previsto inicialmente
daniela cuéntenos cómo están los
indicadores de la jornada wall street'
celebró hoy -por partida doble- de nuevo
un nuevo recorte en dos de sus índices
nasdaq y standard and poor's así empezó
con pie derecho septiembre luego de
sellar su mejor agosto en 30 años las
bolsas europeas cerraron con resultados
dispares luego de conocerse varios datos
económicos entre ellos el desempleo y en
américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
recuperó las pérdidas de la jornada
anterior
bueno y la cifra del día son los 213
millones de dólares en ganancias que
tuvo la plataforma azul entre febrero y
julio de este año los meses más fuertes
de la pandemia el resultado es 27 veces
mayor al de hace un año y catapultó su
acción en wall street en más del 40% de
liga gracias por la información y
ustedes a mí gracias continúen con más
entradas 24 punto com
i
[Música]